can we talk about number 87 yes Rob
Gronkowski so I think it's okay to say
that the Gronk is better known for his
partying than his dieting but is he
following the tv12 method now you know
I'm really proud of him and I've seen
him you know grow up you know he was
such so young when he got to our team
and now he's one of the older players
and he experienced some really tough
things over the course of his career and
I think sometimes when you do that you
know you correlate football with pain
and that's not fun
nobody wants to be in pain football is
actually not fun when you're hurting you
know and I think Rob has really tried to
take a different approach this year and
has been really focused on his hydration
his nutrition and certainly all the
pliability treatments and you know
hopefully it really pays off for him
again it's you know I don't want to make
predictions for him on his season or
what he can do I mean there's a lot of
things that we need to do to accomplish
it but I'd say he's built a good very
strong foundation which is important for
all of us athletes we're about to go
into this portion of our life that
requires you know a great energy output
and you know you've got to build up this
foundation so it can sustain itself over
the course of a long season